so let me start by saying i had a lot of
fun watching this and the chemistry
between tom and mark is you know it's
kind of good you know it's okay yeah i'm
pretty charming and uh
and lovable those two and i feel like
they've really harnessed that nade solid
dynamic from the games which is uh super
important yeah no no listen i the the
reason this film works is because you
believe in their relationship and
they're both very good in the roles um
if someone has actually never seen
anything you've done what is the first
thing you want them watching and why
probably the first movie i made which is
zombieland and i think that was like
you know
for me
such a huge learning curve
as far as what it takes to make a film
and
put together a great cast and
capture a tone and deliver you know lots
of comedy and lots of action which seems
to be my
calling card these days uh uncharted has
been in development since like the 1950s
why do you think it's taken so long to
get the movie made
i don't know it all kind of predates me
when i read the script i was blown away
by you know the spirit of the movie
it totally captured the tone of those
classic treasure hunting films like
raiders the lost ark or national
treasure
which is
a beloved genre for myself and so as
soon as i read the script i thought it
was amazing so i couldn't i couldn't
speak to what preceded me but i know
that as soon as i got involved
i was so excited to go make it
how did you guys actually decide on
which like treasure hunt was going to be
in this movie if you will
yeah i mean the magellan story
predates me as well but i think that it
was a
an effort on parts of the right on the
part of the writers and uh i'm sure the
game makers uh to come up with an
original story specific to the film
that's unique from the video game
franchise but has the same spirit of
adventure
that the video games are known for there
is a fantastic action set piece in this
movie which is the cargo plane with the
the boxes coming out and uh all of that
i can't imagine the challenges of trying
to put this on screen so can you sort of
take me through the behind the scenes of
why this was a sequence you wanted to
put in the movie and just trying to get
it on screen yeah absolutely i mean it
was it was
probably the
the sequence in the film most inspired
by the video games because it it was
featured in one of the games a very
similar set piece and so we had that as
inspiration both as a
um
[Music]
idea that we wanted to execute as well
as like an idea that hopefully fans
would recognize and appreciate from the
the original video game series
um as far as the
execution of it i mean it was certainly
the most complicated thing i've done on
an action standpoint we use in order to
achieve the feeling of the boxes
floating behind the plane
we use these things that they're i guess
they're called kuka arms and they're
basically the robots that they use to
make cars and so the boxes were placed
there was five kook arms and the boxes
were placed on top of the arms and that
allowed them to be
kind of in this
fishtail kind of motion that as if they
were hanging out of a plane and
um obviously we didn't shoot it outside
the back of a plane um and then it was
just a matter of tom and the stunt guys
uh navigating that uh we have an
incredible second director scott rogers
who
is his greatest strong suit is um
rigging and so
he approached it with a really keen
sensibility that allowed us to use
gravity
to help sell the reality of what the
characters are experiencing
and
that combined with some pretty heavy
visual effects
allowed us to create hopefully what is a
a really um noteworthy and iconic action
set piece
what is it like actually reading
something like that in this in the
script and being like
like does it sort of floor you like wait
a minute how the f are we going to pull
this off
there's a degree of that but also
there's excitement because so much
action has already been done before like
you know we've seen it all at this point
and that i'd never seen before so i just
got excited at the prospect of having
the opportunity to make something
completely original and you know
exciting and fresh
that hopefully audiences would
appreciate it uh i love talking about
the editing process with directors
because it's where it all comes together
did you have a much longer cut of the
film or was it pretty much like what
people are seeing on screen is really
you know you know what i mean
no it's always a process i mean i think
every director's cut starts out
significantly longer than the finished
version of the film in this case you
know we were
well over two hours
um but i'm of the mind that
movies are
best when they're
kind of really swift like if you look at
my films none of them are very long you
know the first zombieland was like 87
minutes
and i stand by
when i look at a listing of a film if
it's over two two and a half three
i don't know it makes me
less excited about it so i i appreciate
a swift film and so as part of the
editing process i'm always trying to
like cut it down to its
essentials
boiling boiling it down to its like best
version of itself and cutting away the
fat
and just keeping it exciting and you
know full of those great movie moments
that that uh audiences love because
ultimately i'm making the film
for the audiences and i want them to be
entertained from beginning to end did
you do any test screenings that impacted
the finished film in terms of the
audience saying you know like they they
wanted more of something or less of
something else yeah i'm a big advocate
for test screenings and especially
coming from a comedy background there's
nothing
better than hearing a movie with an
audience
which was a little challenging in this
covet environment just because masks are
an impediment i feel like to the
experience and so even just looking
around a room and not being able to read
people's faces like are they liking are
they not liking it
you rely more on audio cues
but since this movie features so much
comedy it was really exciting to hear it
with an audience because the laughs were
big and they were consistent throughout
and um yeah i i really feel like at the
end of the day the audiences
um
who we make the movie for and and i want
them to have a say in the finished
version of the cut
you have an after the credit scene what
when did you decide you wanted to have
an after the credit scene and was it
always that scene we
always
wanted after the credit scene
um we had
i don't know if i'm speaking out of
school april can tell me if i am or not
but um we definitely had a after the
credit scene uh always intended to tag
the movie
and kind of provide a
[Music]
a suggestion of nate and sully's next
adventure
um
the one that we shot was kind of
compromised because of the schedule
we just couldn't make it as big or as
exciting as i wanted it to be and then
when when it played it was just kind of
like a ho-hum
ending and i really wanted something
that
got me excited certainly so um i was a
big advocate of reshooting that
and um
and uh
and without giving anything away
you know there's a signature look to one
of the characters that's featured in the
tag and that um was always a key part of
the tag
uh from in both versions and that was
super important to us was allowing
the character to kind of grow into
his more familiar look from the games um
and so that was super important as well
as
just the suggestion that nate and sully
will be off on more adventures together
in the future
the the reshot version
after the credit scene is very good um i
don't want to do a spoiler but i do want
to ask you there is something else um
after the credits if you will like a
character um did you cast that person
uh specifically is that person who's in
the movie the person who will be playing
the role in the future or is it sort of
like grades so you can't really tell who
it is if you know what i mean
i feel like um time will tell as far as
what the future holds for that character
and who may uh embody him
uh my last my last question for you
because i'm already out of time uh
assuming this movie is a hit is uh have
you already been thinking about possible
sequels and stuff is it something that
you're interested in pursuing as a
director yeah i make no assumptions uh
there you know it's a crazy world that
we live in these days so i certainly am
the last person to make assumptions but
i will proudly say i'd be thrilled
at the opportunity to make a sequel and
you can't help
you know working on this film for two
years i can't help but imagine different
adventures that these guys might find
themselves on
and i'd be thrilled to
to figure out a way to bring those to
life but ultimately the audience will
decide that's something that they're
excited to see
yeah i think i think tom is a good luck
charm uh but anyway thank you thank you
for all the good luck we can get uh but
yeah tom tom's pretty amazing and we
were lucky to have him at the center of
this film
i gotta go thank you so much for your
time i really sincerely hope it's a huge
hit
you